according to this poll Trump does better
than DeSantis against Biden according to
Emerson 44 would vote for Biden 43
percent would vote for Trump and 43
percent would vote for Biden versus
DeSantis and only 37 percent would vote
for DeSantis here's where it gets kind
of weird if Cornell West the leftist
populist candidate is in the race on
Election Day
then only in that circumstance does the
Republican win Trump 41 Biden 40 Cornell
West six percent you know me I am the
most skeptical of polls and statistics
broadly as anybody gets but especially
this far out especially National polls
but this is really interesting not
because of what it says about Trump and
DeSantis not even really what it says
about those guys versus Joe Biden it's
the Cornell West thing Cornell West
pulls votes not from Trump but from
Biden